she's a comedian activist best-selling
author of the new book life will be the
death of me
and you to our favorite oh she's on a
sit-down comedy tour starts April 11th
in Boston at the Orpheum Chelsea
Handler's back
[Applause]
[Music]
no no whatever you think I can apply to
you Jesus Christ what are you could
insane new rules we'll get to that too
but I you know I'm reading your book and
I'm feeling like a bad friend because I
didn't realize you were suffering so my
movie Oh everybody took the 2016
election hard but I didn't know it
really knocked you down like that and it
came you came back stronger that's what
the book is about yeah I had a midlife
identity crisis once Trump won the
election because I had never had my
world filled so feel so unhinged I think
and I had to pay a psychiatrist to
listen to me [ __ ] about Donald Trump
for about the first three weeks and then
once we got past that and we got to the
real stuff I realized the parallel there
was my world becoming unhinged when I
was a little girl my brother died when I
was nine years old I had never related
the two but for me as I can imagine it
must have been for so many people it was
a huge emotional trigger of everything
being destabilized and I realized just
how spoiled and privileged I'd been all
my life to realize they should be this
upset in this out of ten everyday and
the outrage and the anger I just wanted
to [ __ ] fight people you know and I
was like I gotta go see it for
psychiatrists I mean there is a lot in
there but what I would call white guilt
that you have and what is what good does
that do I mean you're right we're lucky
some people are lucky others aren't
that's not fair life isn't fair but I
think you can also focus on becoming a
better advocate
Ally for people for marginalized
communities and stop looking inside your
own brain and look outside others but I
said but I learned
but there's a lot of you know white so
lame there's a lot of white people
hating on themselves I don't think
that's what the personal it doesn't help
minorities I don't think the oh boy that
makes me feel a lot better she hates
herself I just feel like we're kind of
like self-flagellating ourselves and
it's not helping it's maybe you don't I
don't I disagree I think so flagellation
is good with regard to this I think
we've misbehave for so long that we need
to get our [ __ ] together and I believe
and I mean I really am trying very hard
to not think about my own experience and
to think about other people's
experiences so in that vein I think it's
important to reach out and go what was
your story like what was your life like
it's not like mine I didn't have that
many struggles you know I've never been
hungry I've never been assaulted and I
think something that you learned through
therapy which was so valid for me is I
didn't think I had a right to be in pain
because I wasn't raped I wasn't molested
I didn't have anything that I deemed as
worthy of being damaged I had a brother
who died and I thought I don't get to be
in pain I have this great life I have a
big career I can do whatever I want and
the fact of the matter is but you have
to everybody has pain and you're yeah
but I mean like just because you have
pain does it mean somebody else doesn't
have pain too or that we have to be in a
competition about it no I don't think
it's a pain competition I think it's
important to recognize I think before
you can be of use to other people you do
need to clear out your own injuries or
clean out your ownership okay but when I
feel shitty I'm not gonna feel bad about
feeling shitty because somebody feels
shittier than me cuz somebody in the
world is always gonna be doing worse
than me and I still feel shitty but I'm
only in my head well then you should
feel shitty I do
no I don't want to feel shitty and I
don't want you to feel shitty mindful
citizen because of it and I woke up I
don't know wakening the best part of it
is that you found weed I could have told
you years ago but Trump led you to
smoking pot right cut down on your
drinking what I discovered was alcohol
and outrage are not a good mix it's like
a hat on a hat so I I pivoted right
pivoted towards weed and cannabis and
for me who's a very active kind of
high-strung person I needed the cannabis
was a gateway drug to meditation for me
I couldn't meditate because I was always
like they needed it and then with
cannabis I was like okay I think I can
maybe meditate now I had my Awakening
and I'm like wait Trump we've got so
many other beautiful things going on
right things happening and while
terrible things happen beautiful things
are being are happening as well and I
think it's important to realize I
understand you're working on something
that would take the Munchie factor out
of smoking pot which would be great for
me mm-hmm right yeah well you're not sad
anymore
anymore
I only said that cause I know it would
bother me if I had been fat but I don't
remember being fat we need to get rid of
them you used to be mean that's over but
come on are you serious that there could
be a strain of pot that did not make us
get the munchies yes and you just have
to isolate the strain because every girl
doesn't want to take weed because she
can't control herself or she - I want
that well you also have to just control
yourself and say well I can't when I'm
stoned
I will eat anything and that's the good
the bad part is that you have this
Munchie thing the good part is you'll
eat anything so if you only have healthy
food in the house you know good option
is to clean out your house so that you
can't get after stuff you know when it's
late night I don't know how to order
food so I'm not going to get anything in
my own I have to know what you think
about Joe Biden and this whole thing I
think Joe Biden is just a grandfather
you know what I mean and he's old and
like I'm I I'm I don't like comparing I
don't like these stories of these women
coming out talking about a man smelling
their hair or kissing the back of their
head I feel like it diminishes people
who have actually experienced it I was
trying to say over there I feel like
this is a not really even a man woman
issue it's an America issue about
perspective we have no sense of
perspective everything has to be DEFCON
5 or DEFCON 1 actually
you